but nothing is more important than the
protection of our children and I know
that all of you here today are
absolutely committed to stamping out
grooming gangs and they're sickening
abuse of young people now it is an
absolutely horrific crime and the fact
that groomer gangs are preying on young
people across our country and our
community is a huge failing both morally
and practically now the problem is more
prevalent in our communities than people
have been comfortable acknowledging and
that's why as prime minister I vowed a
major Crackdown to bring the
perpetrators of this awful crime to
justice so today we're launching a new
grooming gang Task Force Police led to
root out these criminal gangs and I want
to welcome members of that task force
here with us today at specialist police
officers are going to be able to be sent
in to communities using the expert
techniques to help us cramp down on
these crimes they're also going to have
a specialist team of data analysts
working with them because we know the
better use of data can help uncover
hidden exploitation and in general we
can't turn a blind eye to this type of
offending we're also going to toughen up
sentencing something as well we'll talk
about and we're strengthening the
national whistleblowing hotline working
together with the NS PCC I think taken
together this represents a very
significant set of actions to stamp out
that's appalling abuse of our young
people you know we should leave no stone
unturned we should keep going until we
can root out this horrific crime that's
what the Home Secretary and I are
committed to doing and we're grateful
for your time and support of this
endeavor today